صوت مجلس الامن على مشروع القرار الامريكي
لوقف هجمات الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر 11
دوله صوتت لصالح هذا القرار امتنعت اربع
دول من بينها حسب ما كان واضحا روسيا ولم
تعترض اي دوله لمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا
المشروع ينضم الينا من الامم المتحده مراس
الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد ابر بنود هذا
القرار استمعنا الى المندوبه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن كانت تعتبر بان هجمات الحوثيين
تهديد سينعكس حتى على ايصال المساعدات الى
الشعب اليمني اعتبرته تهديد عالمي بما
معناه
بالفعل هذا ايضا ورد في نص القرار ذاته من
انه ايضا سوف يؤدي الى
ازمه في الاقتصاد
العالمي
لكن من محتوى هذا القرار هو مجرد رساله
تحذير
للحوثيين ليس الا هو يدين هذه الهجمات في
جنوب البحر الاحمر كما يفعل جميع اعضاء
مجلس الامن بمن فيهم روسيا والصين ويطالب
بوقفها ولكن الاهم من ذلك انه يشير الى
مساله حريه وضمان حريه الملاحه في البحر
الاحمر والى حق الدول وفقا للقانون الدولي
في الدفاع
عن سفنها بطبيعه الحال من هجمات كما يشير
النص تقوض حريه الملاحه الدوليه وه هذه
الماده تحديدا اعترضت عليها روسيا وقال
مندوب روسيا انها انه انها لا توجد في
الواقع في القانون الدولي ولذلك هي طرحت
تعديلا بهذه الماده وتعديلا اخر يضيف
الاشاره الى الصراع في غزه بحسب المنطوق
لان هذا القرار يتجاهل تماما الحرب
الدمويه في غزه ويتعامل مع ما يحدث في
جنوب البحر الاحمر على انها قضيه
منفصله امر لا توافق فيه روسيا ولا الصين
ولا العديد من
الدول مع الولايات المت حده والدول
الغربيه بهذا الشان ولذلك جاءت الاشاره في
التعديل الروسي لغزه وايضا الى ان تعديل
ثالث ايضا الى ان ما ان هذا القرار لا
يشكل سابقه او اضافه الى القانون الدولي
الراهن بطبيعه الحال لم تحصل التعديلات
الروسيه على اصوات كافيه المشروع الامريكي
ايضا لم يقابل بديتو روسي وجر التحفظ الى
الامتناع عن التصويت صحيح
وهي بالفعل وروسيا حذرت من ان قرار كهذا
في الواقع
يفاقم التوتر
و سيؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد في المنطقه
خطاب روسيا في مجلس الامن واضح بهذا الشان
من ان معالجه الازمه في جنوب البحر الاحمر
ليست منفصله عن الوضع في غزه ومن ان وقف
اطلاق النار والسماح بادخال المساعدات
مساله اساسيه لمعالجه هذا الت في جنوب
البحر الاحمر نتوق